make no mistake about it the MCU shuri
is a genius not only does she manage to
find the inner strength to become the
latest in the long line of wakanda
protectors and black panther wakanda
forever but she first uses her
considerable scientific knowledge to
create a genetically engineered
heart-shaped herb that seems to be at
least as powerful as he original however
even a Super Genius can have bad days
and black panther are kinda forever
gives shuri plenty of those pachala dies
off screen in the beginning of the movie
and even after the one-year time skip
she's still dealing with her brother's
death when she loses her mother ramonda
as well perhaps it's because of her
furious state of mind or simply because
she's not yet a very experienced leader
but there's no denying that shuri's
ultimate plan to defeat anymore doesn't
exactly sound like it was made by a
genius when Sherry and Riri figure out
that the seemingly invincible name all
becomes weaker when he doesn't have
access to water they decide to lure him
into a massive evaporation chamber that
strips him of excess humidity and drains
his power this is a good plan however
the way shuri chooses to go about it is
less good wakanda forever establishes
that Neymar's people are a tough nut to
crack as long as they're in water a
talocaniel can breathe underwater they
have all sorts of ocean-themed weapons
use whales as Train transport and attack
animals are able to cause floods can
hypnotize Sailors with the power of song
and genuinely do what they like as long
as they're in their aquatic element
what's more they're super strong and
appear to vastly outnumber the wakandans
as such you'd expect that shuri would
avoid Open Water like it was on fire
like say by building the dryer device
somewhere not so close to the water and
using the vibranium detection machine to
lore name or there however instead of
choosing a ground-based strategy shuru
decides to fight Neymar by hauling a
handful of a best for condom Warriors I
was in the middle of the ocean and
engaging the full might of talocan on
Neymar's home turf all of this is done
in order to law Neymar a powerful flying
mute since you can disable aircrafts in
seconds aboard a plane that contains the
only reasonable shot at drying him up
the plane of course flies directly above
the very wet ocean as this happens that
can't be good they managed to get Neymar
in the drying machine but they
apparently haven't considered the
possibility that the 600 year old flying
man might start destroying the plane the
second he realizes what's up from that
point on shuri has to wing it luckily so
because her improvised plan proves
vastly superior to the original she
panicked lands the aircraft in a nearby
desert and osmally wins the day for the
land lovers it's a close call if shuri's
original idea had gone according to plan
she would be risking all-out war with
talocon sure he drafts a seafaring plan
with the intention to kill Neymar after
umbaku specifically wants her that
talukan will never stop attacking
wakanda if their God King dies by her
hand
killing him we'll risk Eternal War
Sherry takes everyone along while
knowing perfectly well that the second
she kills Neymar the talukanil would
murder swarm her crew and stop at
nothing to topple wakanda as such
Sherry's plan essentially sentences her
comrades to death and they only happen
to be spare because she has a last
second change of plan not the best way
to start your new job but hey all's well
that ends well
[Music]